[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24
líbano conmemora el primer aniversario
de la explosión en el puerto de beirut
que dejó 200 muertos más de 6000 heridos
y 5 millones de euros en daños
materiales
la conmemoración estuvo acompañada de
nutridas protestas contra el gobierno
para exigir culpables y justicia por las
víctimas
la oms se pidió una moratoria a la
tercera dosis de la vacuna contra el cob
y 19 hasta tanto los países menos
favorecidos y poblaciones vulnerables
puedan acceder a ellas el organismo
indicó que el 80 por ciento de las
vacunas suministradas a nivel mundial ha
ido a parar a países de ingresos altos y
medios
y ya está en territorio polaco bajo
asilo humanitario la treta bielorrusa
christina simán usca ya quien denunció
que podría ir presa al regresar a
belarús por negarse a competir en los
olímpicos de tokio 2020 en una categoría
para la que no estaba entrenada para
sustituir a otra atleta
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos hasta
ahora vamos a comenzar el medio oriente
en líbano este país conmemora el primer
aniversario de la explosión en el puerto
de beirut la capital del país que dejó
más de 200 muertos unos 6.500 heridos y
daños materiales por unos 5 mil millones
de euros debido a la onda expansiva que
abarcó cerca de 10 km miles de
ciudadanos participaron en los actos
conmemorativos para rendir un homenaje a
las víctimas que dejó esta explosión
asimismo las calles de beirut fueron
también tomadas para exigir justicia por
este caso y para presionar al gobierno
en el avance que tiene que tener la
investigación para que lleve a
esclarecer las causas de la explosión y
también determine responsables esta
explosión agudizó el descontento de los
libaneses también una profunda crisis
social y política que ha dejado cuatro
primeros ministros en los últimos años
que no han conseguido conformar un
gobierno de coalición estable el bonet
corresponsal de france 24 en la capital
libanesa
detalles en su reporte
acompañamos a un grupo de manifestantes
a una de las tantas marchas que se están
celebrando de forma simultánea en el
centro de beirut para reclamar justicia
por las víctimas del puerto de beirut
por las 215 personas que murieron el 4
de agosto del año pasado después de un
año las autoridades prometieron que en
cinco días se conocerían las causas de
esta explosión pero un año después
todavía los libaneses se siguen
preguntando qué ocurrió ese 4 de agosto
los libaneses culpan a la élite
gobernante de haber conducido al país a
la ruina total de haber no protegido de
forma deliberada a sus ciudadanos por
haber permitido que 2.750 toneladas de
nitrato de amonio explotaron en el
centro de beirut es por eso que hoy los
libaneses se han unido para pedir
justicia y para recordar a las víctimas
de esta tragedia porque si no es así
la explosión del puerto de beirut podría
caer en el olvido institucional ya que
las autoridades están obstruyendo la
investigación al no levantar la
inmunidad procesal a los altos cargos
imputados y hablamos ahora de la
organización mundial de la salud que
pidió una moratoria para la tercera
dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19 la
oms afirmó que entiende la preocupación
de los gobiernos de israel de alemania
que ya van a empezar a inocular las en
sus habitantes pero pidió una prioridad
a las poblaciones vulnerables que aún no
han recibido vacunas contra el
coronavirus we need and jentzsch rivers
el necesitamos revertir de manera
urgente que la mayoría de las vacunas
que van a los países de altos ingresos
se vayan a los de bajos ingresos going
to love in camp countries
according li en consecuencia la o ms
está pidiendo una moratoria para los
refuerzos hasta al menos finales de
septiembre para permitir al menos que el
10% de la población de cada país esté
vacunado place jon of every contratos
vaccinated vamos hasta américa latina'
las autoridades de nicaragua arrestaron
e inhabilitaron a berenice quesada la ex
en reina de belleza y también aspirante
a la vicepresidencia de ese país que
forma parte de la opositora alianza
ciudadanos por la libertad el lunes
pasado quesada había oficializado su
candidatura como fórmula
vicepresidencial de óscar sobalvarro
para las elecciones que están previstas
para el mes de noviembre pero fue puesta
en arresto domiciliario si bien
simpatizantes del xanthi mismo la
acusaron de apología del delito las
autoridades nicaragüenses no han ni
confirmado ni desmentido esta denuncia
y el grupo talibán reivindicó el
atentado contra la residencia del
ministro de defensa en la ciudad de
kabul la capital afgana que dejó al
menos 12 muertos y 22 heridos el ataque
suicida fue confirmado por el portavoz
del talibán que también indicó que era
parte de una operación de venganza
contra importantes funcionarios de la
administración pública
las más recientes explosiones en kabul
son tan solo la punta del iceberg de la
escalada de violencia en afganistán los
talibanes están intensificando sus
operativos contra el gobierno tras la
salida de las tropas de eeuu y la otan
mientras que los civiles quedan en el
medio claramente están expandiendo su
conquista o reconquista abierta de
afganistán hay ataques complejos en
ciudades y contra puestos militares pero
tienen también una ola de asesinatos
selectivos
esto es para aterrorizar a los civiles
afganos la violencia escaló a partir del
primero de mayo que era inicialmente la
fecha límite del retiro de las fuerzas
estadounidenses tan sólo entre mayo y
junio diferentes grupos oficiales y no
oficiales mataron a casi 800 civiles la
peor cifra de dos meses que ha
confirmado la onu desde sus registros de
el ataque más sangriento fue la racha de
explosiones el 8 de mayo contra un
colegio femenino en kabul que mató a
cerca de 85 personas la mayoría eran
niñas
primero fue el coche-bomba y luego la
segunda explosión y después la tercera
corría al lugar y me encontré cuerpos de
niña sin manos sin cabezas y sus
cadáveres apilados uno encima del hogar
bando aunque afganistán enfrenta un
repunte de la violencia el país nunca ha
estado en una paz total según la misión
de la onu en el país entre 2009 y 2020
se ha mantenido la cifra de civiles
muertos 2018 ha sido hasta ahora el peor
año con más de 3.800 civiles asesinados
por diferentes grupos y ahora las
muertes de 2021 se acercan cada vez más
a las de ese año así las cosas el retiro
de las tropas extranjeras sí marca una
antes y un después en el país aunque su
presencia no significó la tranquilidad
completa en afganistán ya está en
territorio polaco bajo el régimen de
asilo humanitario la atleta bielorrusa
cristina azziman usca ya la atleta de 24
años fue acogida por polonia al
denunciar que temía ser arrestada a su
regreso a belarús por haberse negado a
competir en los olímpicos de tokio 2020
en una categoría para la que no estaba
entrenada para sus
mira si a un atleta que no pasó el test
de doping rosa pérez nos cuenta más
teóricamente fuera de peligro y con un
visado humanitario polaco
la atleta bielorrusa cristina chamán
usca ya abandonó este miércoles los
juegos olímpicos en dirección al exilio
tras dos noches en la embajada de
polonia en japón antes de llegar a
varsovia ciudad que acoge varios
opositores de lukashenko
la corredora de 24 años hizo escala en
viena donde fue recibida por las
autoridades austríacas y por supuesto
está preocupada por su familia pero está
bien está cansada y triste por los
hechos de los últimos días pero como
decirlo estuvo bien posicionado
el trayecto de chamán osca ya iba a ser
directo desde tokio hasta varsovia pero
fue modificado por razones de seguridad
con el recuerdo todavía presente del
avión de ryanair que lukashenko desvío
en mayo para detener al opositor román
protosevich
durante los juegos la atleta crítico de
decisiones deportivas de su federación
en consecuencia el domingo dos miembros
del cuerpo técnico bielorruso la fueron
a buscar a la villa olímpica y la
llevaron al aeropuerto en un intento de
repatriación forzada del que escapó con
la ayuda de la policía japonesa y del
comité olímpico internacional que ha
anunciado una investigación formal de
fútbol y ver si su oficina para rally
white y hemos recibido un informe del
comité olímpico nacional que será
evaluado además el coi ha decidido abrir
una comisión disciplinaria para
esclarecer los hechos y para escuchar a
los dos oficiales
artur human y tour y hoy se dijo que
estarían implicados en este incidente
el incidente sucede un año después de
que estallara nuevamente con fuerza el
movimiento ciudadano contra lukashenko
mientras el régimen está cada vez más
aislado a nivel internacional
es todo por el momento aquí en las
noticias de france 24 buenas tardes
[Música]